I will be my leg in Bosnia waiting
for shapes forest landscape commander ratko
mladic final at a tightrope nearly three
decades of the war that kill more than
one to a thousand people
a kind of million heckling afm
jog wheel providers.be defense and sometimes
only john  dean post for you chocolate
was found guilty of john aside and
srebrenica again wrong a break muslim
men and boys wrong ninety nine to
five
who was if i was a white de for crimes
and crimes against humanity during the
war in bosnia for ninety nine to to to
ninety nine to five
that was it quick charge and aside
another part of bosnia
the passion fusion het piel this sinbad
this wheel was rejected
it was an api of bla teach the fence
loyens 17 i'm going to shower tug this
will be criminologist never be free cam
model i  kill the ladder chill stuff here
from never taste freedom
you will talk then in double swing
at even when aso boss something loose her
seventeen your rosalind rubber nothing to
twenty-two gave her a break
she traveled to the hake in a hope to
find some closure and minimal minimal
talk this through you al you sit a minimum
who can expect from justice
and she victim or never be satisfied well
who has a focused on an expert  the
venus on know site where still free
how welcome everything is burned his
main piece of jewelry in the most heaviest
that they talkie private the former yugoslavia
grandstand everything in it where the success
stories for international justice with
long to the chicks that man in that it
suspects  pro to court it also sixteen
years to find a large and bring him to
the hague
my i could not believe i would have
faith trial what this I become the sinus
umpire closure and add example on
international justice is that injury by
hilde moens on survival sturdy  here one
with some people still blower [ __ ] that
really picks up it war criminals seems to
me load this ideology body survival
atmosphere dat logic witsel forge and aside
and other  parts of bos jan wils and the
room message sun statements and
in the in driving this for the ship some
support to the perpetrators
and to people were na je so chen site
ever happend
deferred i then overnight accommodate the
flipkens and door suffering maybe
attraction  another warrior winds in
back
it's not clear hermela davis ever the
eight years old and so for several
strip full-service present you
agree to an appeal to all its member
states special job to offer imprisonment
door de mind with considered one of the
world  war criminals
of all time step of chanel jazeera de
hot